the longest running show on the strip
legends in concert
is back earlier today i spoke with mc
frank moreno
about the return to the tropicana frank
marino
welcome back how are you feeling buddy
i'm feeling really great i am so ready
to get back to work so when does the
show start what's the actual return date
for legends in concert
legends and concert starts on the 27th
of may it'll be
uh three nights a week to start it'll be
thursday friday saturdays at 7
30 and then of course then as the crowds
come back to vegas when things open up
they're going to add on another day and
another day until it's the
normal full week so if you've been
exercising or driving special to stay in
uh performance
shape when i tell you i've been
exercising like crazy
i've been uh practicing in the high heel
shoes
i have i've been doing writing new jokes
i want to make sure they're really cool
you know not intensive jokes so you know
how it is these days but i want to talk
about
i knew it was a really strong disease
when kovit was able to keep men out of
the bars and
get them home to their women by 10
o'clock every night so you know stuff
like that
and your your official role is you're
you're emceeing everything
um so are you are you are you done up as
john rivers you come out as yourself
what's your actual role in the show
yeah so i'll be doing drone rivers we're
also going to have elvis presley rod
stewart and of course miss tina turner
and i'll be like the silver thread that
ties it all together in between every
axe
and you know where all the beautiful bob
mackie gowns and stuff that we do all
the time
yeah i think it's very special that you
guys are coming back here at the end of
the may at in the
end of may because legends in concert
the first very show
was may 5th 1983. what's it like to be
part of the longest running show
on the strip well can i tell you from
day one i used to
go see that show as a fan i was on the
john river show one day and she said
what would you do if i passed away i
said i'd have to join legends at concert
but yes one of my favorite shows that
i've ever seen
and also i'm the longest-running
headliner on this trip i came the
following year in 1984
so there's a really good marriage there
so two icons uh the longest running show
and the longest running performer in las
vegas
you look like you did back in 1984
you're ageless frank moreno
well that's why i keep coming on your
show because i enjoyed those compliments